sanitizing the busiest public transport
system in the United States city
officials say all of New York's 472
subway stations and 4,000 subway cars
and buses have been cleaned and will be
every 72 hours all to try to prevent an
outbreak of coronavirus or kovat 19 it
will decrease the presence of viruses
both both the kovat 19 and others on our
facilities but it will also give
passengers our customers a sense that
we're doing everything we can
New York is yet to see a major outbreak
of coronavirus at least so far but
officials are planning for the worst
because there are so many people here on
any given week day more than one and a
half million people pour into New York
City from the outer areas every day more
than five and a half million commuters
use the public transportation everything
from the subway to the bus to the trains
and every year New York City receives
more than 60 million tourists that's a
lot of hands touching things the problem
though with wiping down the subways is
it's unclear how long it keeps surfaces
contamination free there is still some
debate about fomites which is
essentially when you touch a surface
that's contaminated you touch yourself
how long can the virus survive on the
surface it's still a matter of debate we
have anything between nine hours to 14
days for now most people here are not
changing their routines I kind of
understand some of the panic about it
but at the same time on
just gonna continue to live my daily
life and you know do the things I
normally do to stay healthy oh my gosh
like traveling arrows like be careful
but there's been a lot of diseases
actually and like the corona viruses
like stats are actually pretty low but
when it comes to the subway stations
they'll continue to wipe everything down
to try to wipe out any coronavirus
worries Gabe rose and Oh al-jazeera New
York